[Music]
our views and our theories about the
world even about history or the
geopolitics of the present tend to be
shaped by the perspectives of the
Western industrial democracies and that
means particularly not just Western
Europe in the United States and North
America but rather just the US and the
UK because of the English language and
the role of the English language plays
in shaping the kind of overall global
discourse however more and more what
we're seeing is that particularly the US
and the UK have fallen a bit of foul of
the kind of you know normative
constructs that we tend to think of for
a normal country given the populism that
is gripping both countries politically
in fact you can't really speak in a
United Way about Western civilization
Canada acts in many ways that are very
similar to Western Europe and countries
like Germany and France have a very
different political economy if you will
then certainly in the United Kingdom or
the United States because they are the
more traditional social democratic
welfare states so within the West
there's the social democratic welfare
states of Western Europe and there is
the more free-market kinds of systems of
the US and the UK so not only is the
West not unified and even if it were it
would still not represent the vast
majority of the world's population and
so another reason why people are more
and more calling into question or the
wisdom the sanctity the universality of
the models of Western economies and
politics is because they really don't
speak to the experience today of 85
percent of the world's population which
are governed in very very diverse ways
now the Europeanisation of the world in
the 19th century did spread
parliamentary democracy and civil
service and some kind of Enlightenment
values around the world and 20th century
Americanization also reinforced to some
degree the virtues of democracy and
entrepreneurial ISM and so forth however
still in this century of a Asian ization
in the 21st century there is a rising
Asian confidence that they can determine
their own political systems their own
models a
to their own circumstances so for
example they're very comfortable in Asia
having a strong role for the state for
the government in the economy meaning
subsidizing industries dictating which
industries should be sort of winners and
be given more support from the
government having more non-tariff
barriers and these kinds of restrictions
and foreign investment and so forth to
help to steer the economy in a direction
that they consider to be stable and
progressive and benefiting the whole
country so that's something that Asians
are familiar with and comfortable with
and it obviously runs afoul of some
traditional Western norms that's one
example there are other examples also
about Asians challenge the Western
conventional wisdom and status quo many
Asian societies even Democratic ones
have a preference for technocratic kind
of government so they elect leaders even
in the democracies like India or
Indonesia and the Philippines but they
want to have a strong executive leader
who is a long-term vision and a real
agenda and program for national
modernization that's gonna uplift the
whole population and they give a long
leash and Trust today some of the most
popular leaders in the world those with
the highest public opinion rankings are
actually Asian leaders it might be Prime
Minister Modi of India or president
duterte of the Philippines when the
Western industrial Democratic
populations look at these leaders they
tend to not think very highly of them
they think of them as people who have a
very illiberal characteristics sometimes
they're even described as thuggish but
in these democratic societies of Asia
they are actually very very popular
because they're also seen as getting
things done a strong executive authority
who's going to get things done is
something that Asians have a lot of
tolerance a lot of patience for if you
will so these are some examples of how
the Asian circumstances and Asian
practices and politics today are
challenging what we tend to think of as
normal or desirable in terms of
political or economic governance and
again so long as Asians are succeeding
they will gain ever more confidence that
their system is not
right for them but potentially a better
system that maybe we should learn from
from what they're doing
[Music]